going live as usual a little later on a
Wednesday but here we go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
[Music]
to your favorite podcast
welcome back to River with Griffin uh
this week
had a situation at The Comedy Store that
I had to handle and it spilled over to
Twitter and I just want to talk about it
went to a doctor's appointment uh for
the baby it's like this weird ultrascan
appointment I want to tell you what
happened there uh plus say goodbye to
Ward Zone one they're shutting down the
servers plus news and notes but welcome
back
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
riffing with Griffin welcome to women
um thanks for being here everybody as
usual you know how we do it uh make sure
you subscribe to the channel hit the
notes hit the notifications so you know
when I'm going live on Wednesdays or
when I'm putting up stand up videos
or anything like that make sure you
check me out there
I'm on Twitch daily
been a little busy recently because I'm
filming an indie movie you know I'm on
one I'm on one of these Productions it
actually got a waiver to shoot I'll tell
you about that that's going well so but
anyways uh I am on Twitch most days and
if you want to be a subscriber to the
show to help if you want to be a twitch
subscriber if you want to be a YouTube
member or a patreon person all that
stuff helps the show so I appreciate you
guys
um you know doing that as usual here on
riff and with Griffin and
um you know yeah that's how we um that's
how we do it y'all death how
we'll do it Today's Show is brought to
you by Factor meals thank you factor
meals factors number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you fuel up fast with
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door head to factorymeals.com
griffin50 5-0 and use code Griffin 50 to
get 50 off thank you factor for being a
show
sponsor and contributor I appreciate
that all right y'all what's up everybody
what's up chat how's everybody how's
everybody doing
um appreciate y'all for being here as
always let me do I'll put a q a up what
you got has I put in every week
um if you have some question or whatever
you're going to say there you know we'll
uh
you know let me know what's going on
what's like what's on your mind what's
on your mind chat uh I see somebody
already
misrepresenting stuff which is something
I want to talk about today being
misrepresented that's the ooh theme of
the day I should have had something on
there for that uh
but anyways um welcome
you know it's like I see somebody said
already dead you ain't on strike you
troll no yes yes we're on strike it's
like yes and no if you they they gave
out waivers sag gave out waivers for
certain Productions that are Indie
Productions that that are going to abide
by all of the things that they're asking
for then they could shoot just many
Productions that are able to shoot and
believe me a lot of people out of work
right now so it's like the little small
crew that we have uh you know may could
you talk about makeup people gliding
people sound people like all the people
that don't get to work you think it's
just the actors that are affected but
it's not so our production is going and
it's going strong and it's going well
but I am busy
so I did that well then um today I did
you know I'm just doing stuff man
shooting stuff but um
and then I'm doing this oh I'm doing you
know because I don't know if you guys
know but I directed Matt rife's last
Netflix not um YouTube special that's
gonna be on it was on YouTube called
Matt Steven Rife dedicated to his
grandfather and so now he's doing
another one and it's a big one it's like
Netflix and some things I was already a
producer but some things happened and I
had to now step in as director so I'm
gonna get a big Netflix credit Eric
Griffin director Netflix and I'm joining
the DGA and everything too so hopefully
that another stage another career move
for your boy
trying to get into the world
um what's going on so today's episode I
have a lot of things not a lot of things
to talk about but like some some chunky
things to talk about uh you know so you
know we went on a doctor's visit I do
want to talk about that because it was
such a weird
20-week scan ultrasound big thing and it
was just such a weird experience we had
at the doctor's office so I'll tell you
guys about that tell you about guys guys
once again about this I was at the
comedy store the other night and there
was uh two drunk hecklers in the front
row just these drunk women and I I went
up last and I'm gonna tell you what
happened the aftermath of that
and cod Call of Duty war zone one
Caldera for dance all the beauty of wars
on one is gone they're turning off the
servers tomorrow they're it's gonna be
gone which is so crazy if you're into
Call of Duty the into the Call of Duty
world and all that so I do want to get
into that plus some news and notes
that's going on around the the crazy
internet y'all
um let's see now what's uh you know how
we do I like to go to I like to go to
um comments
and if you have a question Now's the
Time to put it in that q a because I'm
gonna go there so again thank you for
all the comments and you know if you
subscribe to the channel or if you're
listening later it's it's nice to write
comments also on the apple and all those
other places because that pushes the
algorithm for people to listen to the
podcast and I appreciate all you people
on long drives all you truckers out
there are you people that with long
commutes that you hit me up and tell me
how you listen to the podcast in the car
or like when you're working out or
everything like that I'm glad to be a
part of your life with my crazy with my
crazy thoughts and I appreciate that for
you always being here okay Chilly Willy
only 20 minutes ago you wrote this one
uh I guess what he was talking about
what was going on with that Danny
Masterson case he said I haven't kept up
with the case but if a friend of mine
accused of something
and I had a chance to see the evidence
myself I might not agree with the jury
you never know juries have been known to
be wrong again I have no knowledge of
this actual case yeah I mean I don't
know I I get what you're trying to say
I'm not a believer in like everything's
a conspiracy type of thing you know what
I mean I think that if you have a friend
if you have a friend a family member
someone you're like you know I'm not
talking about some casual co-worker or
something like that you know maybe you
have somebody you've known 20 plus years
this is you've been in their life you
know their kids they know your kids you
know what I mean and then they do
something terrible or they're accused of
something terrible and they go to a
trial and and then it's like man what
are you supposed to do you know I mean
some people feel like you know they like
to tell the internet that they would
just be like I'm out of here you know
they love to they people like to say
that they would do that but I don't
think you would for your brother or your
sister your cousin or someone you really
knew no matter what they did you know
and also though I that being said if you
are someone that is like you know you
have a strong moral core or you just
feel like oh because I had no people
that like have a brother or sister
someone really close to them and just
the way they treat them they don't talk
to them anymore so I totally get that
too so it's like yeah you make sure but
don't be don't be guard somebody that
like is like hey I'm trying to look out
for my friend doesn't mean you condone
bad behavior doesn't mean you think
they're innocent you just like support
your friend and you're sad or whatever
it is like that so it's a tough
situation
um this is a good question the lasers
eight
Griff if you could direct and make any
type of film with an unlimited budget
what kind of film would it be and why
man that's a good question and I wish I
would have looked at this one ahead of
time but just off the cuff I think I
would want to make a Sci-Fi
comedy maybe even a Sci-Fi dramedy I
should say you know it's like my own
version of Star Wars but with just funny
people but also you know with you know
with real moments just like a real
moment you know so it's not campy it's
not
it's not woke it's just real moments but
I because I love sci-fi universe so it
would probably be something like that
um
this guy himoro hamara Jen May 6416
another stupid name i i a live intro
every podcast am Griff your top shelf
like a bottle of Richard I don't even
know what a bottle of Richard is uh
Scott Barkley just wrote Tom Cruise is
the goat
maybe oh maybe because I was talking
about uh whatever movie Top Gun or
whatever Mission Impossible yeah I
really enjoyed that you know I'm just
gonna casually just real quick throw
this in I saw
um what do you call it equalizer three
Denzel Washington I really enjoyed this
movie it's just like a standalone movie
so maybe I maybe I'll give like a brief
review of the movie I don't know if
we're supposed to support movies or not
but it's already been made what are we
supposed to do like go watch it
oh somebody said
circa11011 take a shot every time Eric
uses the word nuance oh that's a very
nuanced joke Two Shots that's two shots
for you people
um oh of course some Anna of course
another girl sees the Matt Rife
interview I'd love to this interview so
much well done
it's funny one of Rachel's friends one
of Rachel's friends uh hits her up
oh you know what's funny let me show you
guys something so when I've been on a
lot of Zoom calls you know about this uh
Matt Rife special so you know we got all
these Zoom calls because I have to talk
to people I'm getting caught up with
everything and you know just getting to
know people and all this right and then
so when I'm on the zoom calls
um let me see oh wait what's going on
here oh yeah when I'm on the zoom calls
I put this in the background wait how
come it's not going live I don't
understand
this stupid thing baby bear I have this
let me wait wait wait I gotta figure
this out this is like really annoying
switch I have it say I have it Go Auto
live
um
you know I have it going Auto live but
it's not working so I don't understand
why it's not working you know so weird
um I gotta do like this I gotta go to
this one and I gotta come back to this
one
there we go look it'll show up now so
this is just for the YouTube people so
when I'm on the uh Zoom calls
that have anything to do with Matt about
like the documentaries or like you know
the the special I have this in the
background
[Laughter]
but anyways so Wonder like yeah one of
Rachel's friends like hits like because
he went to my wedding so like a couple
of the girls that went to the wedding
you know they're all like hey
um I saw Matt went to your wedding
um is he like I'm you know he's so my
type and I just you know I'm single
right now you know is there a way you
can hook us up
like people are so it's like people are
so ridiculous you know what I mean so
ridiculous man it's like no I'm not weak
it's like no I'm not hooking you up you
know
all right anyways that was a lot all
right
um
uh Ash
I think it's Ashlyn Ashland Hart 5190
your intro is the absolute best of all
intros thank you and then Mike
knightmare oh nightmare three I've left
my girlfriend before for lagging a lot
my wife gets upset get another one life
is short oh God that's terrible anyway
whatever a lot of good a lot of good um
a lot of good things today comments
today let me just go take a quick look
at
if there's any q a questions today uh if
anybody has said anything here hold on
let's go to this questions questions
when is your next comedy special
um Jay Lou I don't know I'm working on
it because I'm not I don't know if I
want to go to some place like HBO
Netflix or someplace like that like
something traditional and try to get
that done or if I'm just gonna do it
myself and put it on YouTube haven't
decided yet
um what do you think of Jordan love with
the Packers I think Jordan love had a
good start but I think Aaron Rodgers
endorsed him I think Aaron Rodgers
before he left he saw how the kid was
playing and he was like this guy's gonna
be good I think he's gonna be okay so
thank you you know I think he's going to
be all right
[Music]
um
what do you think about the UFC this
weekend didn't watch it I'm not really a
major UFC fan where to the point where I
want to watch it and like get the
pay-per-view I'm not there yet I do
appreciate it way more the violence not
just the violence that bugs me it's just
like I appreciate more now the chess of
it the the different techniques the
different ways some people grapple some
people box some people use Taekwondo
some people use different martial arts
methods to like win the fight and I love
seeing how people some people adjust
some people don't some people think that
they're that what they're great at is
better than what the other person is
great at but Styles make fights and when
people don't change their style I think
they lose I mean it's very interesting
so UFC I'm becoming more of a fan for
sure though
um Griff how do you feel about acting or
being involved in independent movies you
know it's great I'm doing an independent
movie right now and it's actually really
great
um you know shout out to the director
Charisse and all the actors in the movie
it's a small little independent and
we're having a good time shooting it you
know so hopefully we get like a big
distribution when all this stuff gets
settled you know and hopefully we could
uh you know you guys will get a chance
to see it
um
anyway whatever
all right so thanks for being here guys
you know thank you as always for being a
part of real family and you know you
know what
right now this is a good time to talk
about our sponsor of the show Factor
you know Factor guys Factor meals
um with a busy fall season already in
swing you might be looking for a
wholesome convenient meals for a
jam-packed days okay I'm gonna tell you
like this I see this the script is in
front of me but I just want to talk
about this because I've gotten factor I
had to test it out and I really like
this if you I'm gonna say this if you're
trying to lose weight and you're having
trouble with portion control
factor is the way to go because it's
going to be the perfect amount of food
you're gonna need perfectly packed ready
to go you're not gonna overeat and it's
great and they are America's number one
ready to eat meal kit all right
um they have so many different
types of meal plans you know all the
different like it's keto it's vegetarian
breakfast lunch you know there's so many
different types of things and you don't
want if you don't want to cook and it's
actually great you know you're not
wasting food you're not
over buying things at the supermarket
when you're trying to cook stuff
everything comes ready to go all right
so I do highly recommend
um Factor meals and what you want to do
guys is you want to head to
factorymeals.com Griffin
50 and use code Griffin 50 to get 50 off
so listen just try it try it I'm telling
you try it it's so easy mailed right to
your door all right try try try it I'm
telling you right now you will not be
disappointed head to
factorymeals.com15 use code Griffin 50
get 50 off that's code Griffin 50 at
factormeals.com
Griffin 50 to get 50
off don't forget to use code 50. Factor
meals thanks for being a sponsor all
right guys uh we did it you know we took
care of our business and now we're here
just to yip Yap about stuff all right
let's talk about this uh doctor visit
that I went on so all right I know you
guys know I've been talking about it you
got the six weeks we had a you know six
weeks it was weird eight weeks I was
like oh man I didn't know we were
supposed to still worry 10 weeks it's
like oh my God we got arms and legs and
they were like oh we're ready to go 14
weeks they checked the nose and the the
spine for like down syndrome and
whatever else so in my mind we're good
to go we're ready to go man I'm thinking
boom we're buying baby clothes it's like
it's really exciting right so then we
have to get this big 20-week scan I
don't know if you guys know about it if
the people with kids modern right now
you know what I'm talking about you know
you go it's like a real it's like an
ultrasound that's like a really intense
Ultrasound with like all different types
of Wands and they're like they're
looking at the baby's brain the spine
the feet counting the fingers counting
the toes uh the the checking the brain
stuff is like huge and checking like the
you know the bone the structure of the
baby and all this stuff right so I'm
thinking I'm just getting some like you
know the next step
all right we're we're in the doctor's
office okay and then we uh we go into
they call us in pretty quick and I'm
like oh that's cool because you know
sometimes you go to the doctor it's got
a one o'clock appointment you there at
like 12 45. they got you wait until 1 15
and then you go into the room and then
by 1 30 the doctor comes in you're like
well this wasn't when my appointment was
my appointment was supposed to be at one
where the hell you been right no we get
in
sign in a few minutes boom we're in
we're now ready to go she's laying on
the table got her belly out we're about
to do this thing in walks the doctor
okay
okay and he walks in real somber like
hey you know and I'm all right okay
what's going on with you he's like hey
guys listen I'm so sorry
um I'm I'm gonna need a lot I'm gonna
need a lot more time because I'm
delivering some really bad news right
now you know he's like in the other room
delivering bad news to people
guys that was the moment I realized uh
oh we could get some bad news today
I was like
why would you do that
you know and then he caught himself
being like hey um I'm gonna bring you
some snacks so he goes to like a vending
machine type snacks and comes back in
with like apple juice box and like some
cookies and stuff and being like listen
uh you know I I need the time I need to
take I don't rush anybody when I'm
giving them bad news and I'm like well
God damn dude so then he he leaves right
so now we're looking at each other like
Oh I thought this was like we're good
already I thought we were having a
healthy baby right so then
in walks another doctor okay and she is
just stone-faced man she's like hi I'm
gonna start the I'm gonna start the exam
for the doctor you know I'm Dr so-and-so
and we're like okay she's way younger
than the other guy right so you could
tell like you know she's like uh not
that she was inexperienced looking I'm
just saying in comparison to the other
doctor obviously he's been a doctor for
way longer so that she starts to test
and it's a long test man stuff this test
goes like an hour okay like an hour or
so
um and then and then we're like all
right so we're in there you know and
this is like a a the big time place like
we're going to like a big time Clinic
you know where we go like this is like a
you know it's a good doctor where we're
going to the place we're going a few of
my friends that have babies have gone to
this you know what I mean like so we
were sent here from our doctor that's
you know anyways
you know so this lady she starts doing
the thing and so it's taken a while and
she's looking and so I'm all trying to
get anything out of her man anything I'm
saying so how we looking uh at this
point could you have seen anything and
she just was like like RoboCop man she's
nothing she gave me nothing you know and
it's just I'm trying my best to coax it
out of her tell me something you know
tell me something you know so finally
you know she's like you know and then
there was one moment where she was like
you know she kept doing a certain area
and I'm like oh my God what's going on
here and then she like you know she says
thank you I'm gonna I'm gonna go uh
confer with the doctor and I'm like just
no bedside manner the bedside manner
like uh oh we're gonna we're that's it
we're having a wolf or something you
know what I mean where there's a gremlin
in my wife's belly so
she goes the doctor comes back in you
know and he's like I'm really sorry
about that then he sits down and he
starts doing ultrasound stuff and he's
like training her on my wife you know
he's like oh I see why you couldn't get
to one shot here's how you do it blah
blah blah and I'm just like my God
people what is happening tell me stop
that you know and then finally the
doctor's like you know you casually like
oh you guys this is great everything's
great everything's great your baby's so
healthy everything's gonna be great you
know but it was like such a
nerve-wracking experience man
you know it was just so because like in
comparison to the other place we go you
know the uh the ultrasound ladies this
French woman and she's like hello you
know oh you're baby it's oh your baby is
moving and kicking and you know she's
just like oh it's so exciting you know
you're just kind of like Yay like this
is who you what you want your ultrasound
nurse to be like just excited and like
being like Oh my God this is great and
so I know if we went back to her and if
she was like stone-faced I would know
something's wrong because the way she's
interacted with us so I was expecting
like something but you know if you're
having a baby or if you've had a baby
you know what we're going through and if
you haven't had a baby it's just like an
an emotional roller coaster from start
to finish man it's so crazy but it was
good I enjoyed the uh you know because
it's good to know that everything is uh
working out
all right let's get to this
Twitter situation
um all right I okay so I'm at The Comedy
Store the other night Sunday night I'm
at The Comedy Store I'm last the
lineup's great it's like Arsenio Hall
and all these kind of people are on the
show and I'm the last guy on the show so
I mean you know I'm in the room you know
and you know the last few Comics are in
the room we're talking they're talking
and there's a situation going on every
comic is like a little annoyed like
there's two people in the front row that
just won't shut up it's like a thing you
know it's not really a lot of security
there on a Sunday night I guess or and
it's the kind of thing where sometimes
people are disruptive to the like where
you go okay well we can't necessarily
kick these people out but they're
ruining the show okay it's like people
are trying to do their set and then
they're saying things oh yeah you know
you know you know what I mean like they
think they're helping they think this is
fun and most of the comics were trying
to like okay let me just get past this
let me try to like work it out but but I
know everyone's freaking annoyed
so I go out I'm last
as soon as I come out they saying
something I ignore them I did this on
purpose I ignored them the whole show
even though they tried their best to
ruin my set
but I smashed it I'm killing it I know
I'm doing I know I'm doing a good set
they're still trying to ruin the show I
could see them people around them
they're disrupting people around them
okay but I don't say anything because
I've had this happen in the past and I'm
gonna tell you what happened to me I was
in Dallas a few months back and there
was a guy in the show that was like
drunk or something was up with him and
he just was like boom and in the middle
of the show I just I had to be like man
what the [__] wrong with you you know
I just went on went in on a guy well
later somebody sent me a message
that was at the show and the guy was
like hey man I just want you to know
like I don't know what was going on
because I didn't hear anything you know
and it just like I don't you really went
in on that guy so hard I don't
understand that and it just really set
to show the tone of the show was just
different and the crowd was weird and I
and that was the moment I was like oh
wow it's because of that see this is
what happens when there's like a big
room if there's a big room and there's a
Heckler there's someone disruptive you
as a comic I may see it and I may see
the people that it's affecting right but
I don't realize is there is a still a
large majority of the room can't hear it
don't know what's going on and they just
want to enjoy the show
so I thought about that so shout out to
that guy in Dallas that sent me that
message because I thought oh you know
what I do want to go off on these two
right now but I'm gonna wait the people
that are here the majority of the people
who deserve my best I will give them my
best so at the end of my show I dealt
with it you know I told him shut up I
just I went in okay was I aggressive yes
because I was upset and I was upset for
all the comics not just for me but for
everyone so I went in on these chicks
you know and I had this thing I do it's
just a trick okay it's just a trick it's
a it's a it's like a it's a little uh
what do you call it
um
Easter egg or not Easter egg but it's a
little you know bear trap or
I forgot what I forgot the term you use
right
but this is what happens especially with
a female heckler
they won't stop right just how you get
them to stop I go you know what
I grant you the last word I'm going to
allow you to have the last word and what
happens is their ego they hear that and
go oh you're not gonna tell me when I
can speak and you know what they do
they don't say anything which is what I
wanted and then I'll say that's how you
get a and I use the c word I'm gonna say
it that's how you get you know to shut
up
right and then and then a large majority
of people cheered
and I sailed off into the sunset
so later I get a message from one of the
comics that was on the show and it was
like hey man you see that tweet you know
because I apparently you know somebody
tweeted at The Comedy Store and me but
like I have my thing locked down where I
don't even see stuff you know so there's
so many trolls and nonsense that I have
they have some great settings on on on
Twitter or X whatever you call it now
that you don't even have to see people
you don't have to even see what they
write you know it's just it's often The
Ether but I checked because one of the
comics was like yo did you see this so I
want to go over it with you guys and
then I'm going to tell you how I feel
about this and what all everything that
went on Okay so
the original post this guy goes great
night at The Comedy Store until Eric
Griffin berated a woman in the front row
that was annoying the comics after
tearing her apart he culminated in
saying and that's how you get a c word
to shut the [__] up he was enraged like
scary abusive husband vibes
I saw this
you know he tweeted at me so I take
offense
so I write back to the guy
the part Mr virtue signal look at me I'm
a good person left out was the lady was
drunk and disruptive to everyone around
her and the comics I waited till the end
to let her know but thanks for the
sideline report
you see my problem with this guys
problem with this is
yes
I was going in on this lady like what's
my overall issue let me let's just go
over that like step by step so we could
talk about this
um
one
as I said these these people were like
the lady was drunk and by the way
in the parking lot she was going at me
in the parking lot too okay that's a
whole other thing
all right so
did I go hard yeah I did
not gonna lie I'm not gonna sit here and
pretend like I was being nice I wasn't
being nice I was being mean on purpose
because I was really fed up with how
these two were being the whole show
what's my issue my issue is that two
things one Mr I'm a good person here
the way he
mischaracterized the whole thing
the way he the way this idiot wrote this
thing he made it out like
like these two weren't doing anything at
all and everything was fine and I like
he he compared me
he called me an abusive husband
basically you know what I mean like what
like that's such not what happened you
know what I mean and this is like
this is like my issue is can we just
have moments without sharing them on the
Internet
that's what it is
can we just have a moment
let's say you win that show and you in
the back and you see me do this and you
didn't even see what was going on you're
like damn he's going in on these people
either you go oh man either you're in
your mind you say well Dan that must
have been some real bad hecklers up
there or you go oh that guy why did he
do that he didn't have to go so hard
then you go oh well I still had a good
show there was 10 other comics on the
show and you go home and you live your
life and you let it go but no
we live in a world now where idiots like
this
want to like hey he wants to show his I
don't even know how many followers he
has probably not a lot let me show them
hey guys do you see what a good person I
am I need to tell you what happened last
night your dumb followers don't know
what happened last night
you just are saying how you want to say
it to paint me off like I'm some crazy
person
and I thought that was unfair
how about you just like go home okay
just go home
this is just like unbelievable just go
home right
and then you know I don't know it's just
it's like I my thing is like I don't
care if you don't like me I don't care
you don't think I'm funny if I'm if I'm
especially like at The Comedy Store you
work a lot of comments are working on
things I might be working on something I
might be trying some taking some
artistic Liberties to try to figure out
my set for when I'm on the road or I'm
doing bigger shows right
and and then people might not like it so
they're gonna be like look I didn't like
that and then they and then the problem
there is then they go to Twitter and
they're like well I saw him talking
about this
oh I saw this female comic saying this
or whatever and I can't believe you know
what it's art we're working on it
this that not everything needs to be
shared to the internet
for what
like this guy trying to make out like
he's
this he's like a white knight and
shining armor from the internet like if
you thought I was being so terrible
approached me after the show then if you
got something to say or in the middle of
the show be like hey man that's too far
did he do that no because he's a coward
that's what cowards do
they immediately go to the internet
act all with their Twitter fingers
keyboard warrior style and then think
like yes ah I just I let all 50 of my
followers know I'm a good person
that's that's what this guy did
guy got like five thousand six thousand
followers talking about he's like a
therapist I'm like what like man imagine
trusting somebody that thinks like that
it's like
this is the world we live in now and my
thing is this again
everything about it was inappropriate
the drunk girls the club not doing
anything about it till the end not
nothing about it not even coming over to
them and being like okay it's time to go
okay hey can we move you to the back
because it seems like you're you know
think my reaction everything was over
the top how about this
when it's done we move on with our lives
and we just go we had that moment it was
good for some terrible for some and we
move on
but no everybody
we have to go to Twitter
and mischaracterize it or go on your
stupid solo podcast oh wait that's me
just kidding you get my point though
right it's like what are we doing you
know what I mean does everything have to
be shared uh you know and like do a
podcast and talk about it you know I
mean it's like but like to tag me
it's one thing to like you're on your
Twitter and more power to you tweet
whatever you want hey hey fans you know
hey fans
um here's what happened to me
uh you know boom boom boom boom boom
right
and then but you tagged me so you wanted
me to see it so now you getting it son
and everybody and I tweeted in back I
tweeted and then at like 95 of the
responses are just like uh dude shut up
dude shut you know and I really
appreciate all the support people that
have for comedy not me for comedy for
the comedy club experience
you know and I appreciate that so shout
out and kudos to all the people that you
know
are are are are a part of this right now
that that that that made it you know
what it was you know what I mean you
know you know and it's like
you know I mean it's just like it's it's
unbelievable
I don't know it's just it really is
unbelievable that people are like this
but whatever it's done I wanted to talk
about it
oh anyways all right
so what else is going on you know I
didn't I didn't want to talk oh let me
just go to some some internet stories
that I have this some more craziness
from the internet let's do that on my
air Griffin topics wait what's going on
here
here oh here we go my Roofing topic Shaw
first one is this I don't know if you
guys saw this
I don't know if you guys saw this thing
about the trumps but so somebody hacked
Donald Junior's account
and posted that Trump had died and I was
like God damn that's terrible
um but you know what this is about
two-factor authentication you know let
me just tell you this guys everything
you have any kind of like public account
Twitter Instagram Snapchat uh email just
all kinds of stuff even your Xbox
account PS5 accounts any accounts you
have information emails or anything you
have
turn on the two-factor authentication do
it right now guys I'm telling you do it
right now do the two-factor
authentication or use the authenticator
app the Google Authenticator app they
have a bunch of authenticated apps you
can use
to protect your information
like I don't know the details of maybe
it was like you know some like if
there's some professional hacker it is
what it is but I'm just telling you a
few common people all of us the rest of
us in the world you got to be careful
don't like
don't you know sometimes you get a weird
text message with a link or sometimes
you get an email that you think is from
Facebook that's like hey your account
has been uh you know deactivated because
of this reason click here to fix it that
ain't Facebook
you know if you get a phone call or a
text message from the government like
hey your your social security number
we're turning it off all that kind of
stuff none of that [__] is real man be
careful out there
you know be careful so right now for
your Instagram whatever social media
account you use the most make sure you
get that two-factor authentication going
to protect yourself so that's what I
thought when I saw this I was like damn
Don Junior you don't got two-factor on
homie
[Laughter]
it just feels like he did it
you know what I mean somebody doesn't
feel like his password was like his
password was just Trump backwards or
something it was crazy so make sure you
guys do that you know what I mean
here's one of these weird internet
stories I thought was super weird
the bride wants to divorce from her
husband after their wedding for smashing
cake in her face
I don't know if this is true but I love
reading these headlines and just talking
about them sometimes so it's not
necessarily had to do with this story
but just the actual concept of this
being a thing how flimsy is your love
for somebody that this is the reason why
you're gonna leave them like you
shouldn't have got married in the first
place if this is why you're gonna leave
somebody they put some cake in your face
then your whole relationship is a fraud
your relationship is a fraud if this is
you know there's so many things that
happen in marriage that you just you
know like you know you you get up you
you might get up and fart in your wife's
face by accident that's some divorceable
stuff compared to a fun tradition that
people do at weddings you know what I
mean
so silly it's like like I say flimsy
your relationship with flimsy what are
you doing
that's all I have to say about that last
story from one of my favorite sites uh
puberty I love puberty you guys should
give them a follow shout out to puberty
turns out Keanu Reeves push for John
Wick's character to be killed off in in
the fourth movie
you know I this happens a lot with these
big stars I remember Sigourney Weaver in
the aliens Series so aliens three
she was a producer and she was you know
part of the you know making sure the
story and she was adamant spoiler alert
that Ripley her character dies okay you
know sometimes you think your career is
gonna last forever and it's gonna always
be this big and at the time she was like
you know Arnold Schwarzenegger Rambo you
know what I mean like Sylvester Stallone
level of like action star like the
aliens franchise was huge okay
she kills herself in the movie she gets
herself killed in the movie
of course
some years later
the life isn't going the way you thought
it was gonna go here comes aliens four
with who Sigourney Weaver where they had
to come up with some weird reason why
she's alive
so I'm not saying that's going to happen
for for Keanu Reeves but maybe he's just
run it's run its course because it's
like how many people are John Wick gonna
kill
how many like the high table that's the
big organization in this movie how many
henchmen can they possibly hire at a
certain point you're gonna hear about
this and be like
nah I'm actually gonna I'm gonna call
John Wick and I'm gonna be on his side
because apparently 700 people ain't
enough to stop him so I'm gonna be with
him
start a new table
you know I want to go to John Wick's
table like if I was a henchman assassin
in the John Wick universe
after four movies
and John Wick has killed 700 of your uh
colleagues
I'm out
right you're like
hey
you text him because they all got the
numbers you'd be like hey John it's it's
Eric uh assassin you know from Culver
City
um yeah man not with the high table
anymore you want to talk you know collab
you know what I mean you want collab
um cuz you know I'm not trying to get in
your way dog I mean what it's like
so maybe he's just done with it because
there's nowhere else to go with this
there's nowhere else to go so I don't
know good job but I just feel like it's
time to go John Wick I'm gonna end the
podcast with something that is really
precious to my heart guys you know what
that is
for all you gaming folk oh wait oops let
me do this I see what the problem is
hold up
I gotta turn this off
this thing never works the way I want it
to work man never you know it doesn't
even make sense or let's go here and
then we'll go back here
boom
there it is well you can't really see
but it's like
Call of Duty
Oh that's oh I had the wrong one the
2.01 but whatever I got my Call of Duty
background so tomorrow officially
Call of Duty and I think this is like
one of the first time well I shouldn't
use it I don't know but in my experience
when a game comes out
you know you have a servers that they
run the game on and so people can still
play those games like Call of Duty Black
Ops is one of the their first battle
royale game I believe
came out right before the pandemic and
that was the first kind of Call of Duty
Battle Royale game I've ever played
and that game's still active right now
it's still active like you can still
play it it's hard to get a game because
there's not a lot of people playing it
but you can get a game right those
servers are still on
so cut to
um then war zone comes out I'm playing
Call of Duty I'm loving it and then
Warzone comes out and it's this massive
Battle Royale game with 150 people on
this beautiful map called verdance and
it's got downtown it's got farmlands
It's got it's this huge map you
interactive playing with 150 people and
a battle royale is like what it is is
there's a circle okay and each after
after like five minutes the circle
closes and the circle closes and you
have to keep heading to the center of
the circle and the last person left is
the winner it's a it's a such a perfect
game it's always different so
I made it through the pandemic playing
war zone
playing Warzone and building up my
channel Eric Griffin gaming by the way
building up my channel daily
uh during the pet you know uh uh making
money streaming turning myself into an
old man streamer and interacting with
the fans and and making some really good
friends like I like shout out to the
Eric Griffin Gaming Community they are
loyal they're gonna help they have
helped me that I'm buying a crib I'm
buying baby stuff with all the gaming
money that I've made thanks to them and
I give them content I interact with them
but these people are great you know I
know that I know some of them by name
I've met them at shows they come to my
shows and all over the country
I got good moderators that are
moderating my channel there's like 10 of
them you know they're great dudes and
it's like they're great ladies both both
sides I got some great ladies out there
svet she's great of Adria she's great
all the all the the the the the girl
mods in my on my Channel all the guys
you know it's like it's great so Warzone
was great we bonded over it and now oh
since then they've changed it so you had
war zone one we had this beautiful map
for dance then there was like all kinds
of things they changed in that which I
did not appreciate and then they were
gonna make a new map and then they had
these side maps of like a smaller Battle
Royale version of the game called
Resurgence right so that's a great game
too and they had these two great maps
for that and we were like rocking and
rolling and the game got to a perfect
point where they fixed the movement in
the shooting and it was like oh man this
is great and then they
made a new map called Caldera and it was
trash
like the worst
and then it was downhill from there and
so then we kept going and then it was
like man this kind of sucks but they
still had Resurgence Maps they had like
rebirth Island and fortunes keep these
two grapes smaller Maps so everybody was
playing that playing that playing that
and then war zone two came out recently
in the last like nine months war zone
two came out and it was a huge
disappointment I still play it every
single day because I love war zone I
love Call of Duty but the map and the
engine and the gameplay it's different
and it's not necessarily what we wanted
but what we what we really want is like
hey still keep these other Maps but of
course they didn't they made it so you
could only play Caldera which everybody
hated and then they had the war zone map
and then this new Resurgence map This
Island
trash island
so then they
so anyways war zone twos here they have
this new map then they have a nut now
they made it they made two new maps and
it's kind of like okay we love these two
maps and we're playing this we're
playing this but there's still people
that was playing Caldera uh and because
they thought that everyone was going to
move to war zone two and it was going to
be this millions of people playing this
game and that's not what happened
they won't even release the numbers you
know Call of Duty and Activision they're
very they're like Netflix they're not
releasing the numbers so you can't see
what people are doing so
now anyways to say all that they're
actually going to turn off the servers
and this is the first time I've ever I
think they've ever done this I take
offense because we had to buy Modern
Warfare we had to buy Modern Warfare we
had to buy Cold War and we had to buy uh
Vanguard I think though I don't know
chat if you're if you're into what I'm
saying do you know if those three if
those if the multiplayer versions of
those games are still on or did they
turn it all off
um yes steam can only see the player
count for steam I see somebody in the
chat that said that dead to rights no
but it doesn't see the entire fan base
of who's playing it's only that server
that they're showing
um but anyways so I don't know if those
multiplayer games are going to get
turned off because I bought all those
games it's like so that's crazy but
there's actually no point like there's
no point in playing Modern Warfare
unless you are a true multiplayer player
you love playing multiplayer but it was
great because it was like cross
pollinating you know you'd be like you
would rank up your guns and multiplayer
and then take them to the big war zone
map so they are turning off the servers
but I just want to say that being said
everything I've said all the crap I'm
saying about it because it's so
frustrating I will say this
um I do appreciate all the people that
made Call of Duty Treyarch
um uh Activision uh you know all the
gaming companies that contributed to
make this really fabulous game
and I'm playing it today because of War
Zone one and it is sad to see the
servers being turned off and it's like
the end of an era I know that they're
looking forward and then like a new
Modern Warfare 3 I believe is about to
come out is that right Modern Warfare 3
because the model for two I don't even
know what what modern warfare are we on
right now but the new one's gonna come
out with a new engine and then a new war
zone you know game experience so I am
looking forward to that
if you're into Warzone uh you know you
can come to my Channel watch me play
sometimes I play with fans I do want to
get back to doing the uh the the Customs
I've just been really busy like guys
tonight I'm flying to DC tonight after
this podcast I gotta pack spend time
with my wife you know I got to do a
little bit of strings I haven't done my
stream and then um you know I'm going to
the airport so I just want to say again
Kudos shout out to
um
Call of Duty the makers of Call of Duty
uh you know I don't I don't know what to
say other than like I've enjoyed you
know I've enjoyed your game you know
what I mean I've seriously enjoyed your
game and you know yeah King I just saw a
post from Jay God and shout out to Jay
God I've had him on the podcast he's
like my favorite nerd ever
um they're shutting down the wars on One
servers Caldera servers which was for
dance and all that stuff they're
shutting the servers down so it's like
wow I don't know it's like like I say it
just reminds me of it's the end of an
era so you know
it is what it is once again I want to
thank factor for being a sponsor of the
show today I want to thank all of you
guys for being here you know even even
shout out to Twitter fingers for like
you know running your mouth you gave me
something to talk about on my podcast
and I appreciate that
um you know y'all y'all know how we do
so right now guys make sure you
subscribe to the podcast so you know
when I'm going live on Wednesdays uh
next week is going to be real tough I
don't know how I'm gonna do that because
I think I'm shooting that day twitch I'm
gonna be on Twitch in like 10 minutes on
10 minutes I'm gonna be on the twitch
and then if you want to be let's support
the show you could be a patreon member
to support the show you could be a
YouTube member to support the show or
you could be a twitch subscriber to
support the show any one of those ways
you want to support the show I totally
appreciate you on that
okay
you know what time it is
it's that rock recap
come on back
put the fingers to get slapped
went to a show
damn hecklers had to go
went home
to a Twitter hoe
Caldera
gone
it's my song
oh people with Griffin
always spliffing
I don't know what that means
but you've been seen
y'all been King
living the dream
I ain't mean
just been seen
about a whole chat
now this recap rap
sometimes I'm fat
but I'm a big cat
all right
I'm actually exhausted those my
exhausted dad Rhymes one day I'm just
gonna write the Rhymes out ahead of time
then I'm gonna be on here flowing and
killing it y'all gonna be like damn
Griff but in the meantime thanks for
watching Remember Griffin and I will see
you next week